[Música]
rusia está bombardeando a la región de
donges que para evitar el reagrupamiento
de las fuerzas ucranianas según dijo el
ejército de kiev los militares de voz de
moscú derribaron un puente ferroviario
que conectaba a las ciudades de
slomianski y liman
el presidente mexicano andrés manuel
lópez obrador y su homólogo
estadounidense joe biden hablaron
telefónicamente ambos mandatarios se
enfocaron en discutir la problemática de
la migración el mandatario mexicano
afirmó que su canciller viajará a
washington
la alta inflación en argentina ha
provocado un aumento drástico en los
precios lo que ha llevado a que algunos
alimentos básicos sean inalcanzables los
comedores populares buscan alternativas
para garantizar una alimentación
nutritiva
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy maría cara calle y comenzamos en
ucrania del presidente de ese país
volodymyr selenski y el ejército acusan
a rusia de bombardear constantemente la
región de donges que en el este según
las autoridades ucranianas para evitar
el reagrupamiento de sus fuerzas y para
deshabitar la zona además en toda la
guerra más de 170 centros hospitalarios
han sido atacados en ucrania según la o
ms nuestras enviadas especiales a
territorio irene sabio y leticia álvarez
nos cuentan como el personal clínico
libre a su propia batalla
la guerra no se apaga en el este de
ucrania clínicas infantiles atacadas y
miles de heridos en todo el país
atenderlos se ha convertido en una
misión difícil para los médicos como
esta doctora que gestiona un hospital en
libro prefiere no mostrar su rostro para
no poner en peligro el centro de salud
no ocurra ni una gran cantidad de
hospitales fueron destruidos en todo el
país a pesar de que tenían la bandera
blanca y que se entendía que eran
hospitales centros para niños
maternidades todos fueron destruidos
desde el cielo a tu gusto pese a los
constantes ataques a los hospitales
andrew quien llegó con una herida grave
en el brazo reconoce que ha sido bien
atendido
me habían puesto un torniquete y como
los combates continuaron no pudieron
evacuar me rápido y estuve mucho tiempo
en la mano con él
170 centros sanitarios han sido atacados
desde el inicio de este conflicto según
la organización mundial de la salud
ataques en los que han fallecido unas 70
personas un combatiente de ser casi
herido por un ataque con misiles en
dones está con vida gracias a la
atención recibida en este hospital de
guerra
agradezco desde lo más profundo de mi
corazón a los médicos que me salvaron la
pierna me devolvieron esperanza y que la
paz pueda finalmente llegar a ucrania
los médicos que trabajan en ucrania se
encuentran librando su propia lucha y
con más fuerza porque son unos de los
principales blancos de ataque en esta
guerra
desde la invasión rusa a ucrania francia
quiere limitar su dependencia del gas
ruso pero este país extrae sus reservas
de gas mediante fracturación hidráulica
o fracking que está prohibida en francia
el dilema es si las sanciones contra
vladimir putin deben anteponerse o no a
las preocupaciones ambientales
detrás de los pintorescos pantanos esta
es la verdadera cara económica de
luisiana las fábricas de gas surgen por
todas partes y un número cada vez mayor
de petroleros gigantes que navegan por
sus canales este se dirige a una planta
que pertenece en parte al gigante
energético francés total
y de lo que ven detrás de mí es un buque
cisterna que transporta gas natural
licuado vamos a ver cada vez más de este
tipo de buques en los puertos franceses
y europeos para garantizar nuestra
seguridad energética en un cargamento
como éste hay un equivalente a casi un
día de consumo de gas en francia
cerca del 40% del gas consumido en
francia procede de noruega el 17 por
ciento de rusia la cuota de eeuu es
actualmente algo inferior al 6% el país
se ha convertido en el nuevo dorado del
gas natural concretamente del gas
esquisto pero se obtiene mediante
fracking un método de extracción
controvertido por su impacto ambiental
que está prohibido en francia sin
embargo estas consideraciones han pasado
a ser secundarias frente al problema de
cómo desligar a europa del gas ruso
ahora a través de total francia se ha
convertido en el mayor exportador de gas
natural americano en los tres primeros
meses de 2002 las importaciones de eeuu
ya han igualado las del año pasado por
lo que este año vamos a triplicar o
incluso cuadruplicar las importaciones
de gas natural liquado estadounidense
al no existir gaseoductos el transporte
del gas a través del océano supone un
enorme reto logístico primero debe ser
enfriado a temperaturas muy bajas para
que se convierta el líquido
reducimos el volumen en 600 veces a su
estado líquido para que sea más fácil de
transportar pues la única manera que
tenemos de distribuirlo por todo el
mundo
y luego inicia su viaje de dos semanas a
través del atlántico almacenado a menos
160 grados centígrados hasta los puertos
europeos la huella de carbono de este
gas esquisto es mayor debido a los
costes medioambientales de la
fracturación hidráulica el licuado y el
transporte y la prisa por construir más
infraestructuras de gas amenaza los
objetivos climáticos a largo plazo pero
este es el precio que partes de europa
han decidido pagar para evitar financiar
la guerra de vladimir putin el
presidente estadounidense joe biden y su
homólogo mexicano andrés manuel lópez
obrador hablaron telefónicamente el tema
central fue cómo controlar la migración
en medio de una tensión pues la casa
blanca quiere acabar una orden que
permite la expulsión de migrantes para
evitar la propagación de kobe 19 nuestro
corresponsal en washington cristóbal
vázquez no se ampliaba previamente la
información
hablaron hablaron durante cerca de una
hora de 52 minutos concretamente duró
esta llamada concretamente no pactaron
nada sin embargo el objetivo de la
llamada lo confirmaron varios oficiales
después de esta fue seguir trabajando
juntos en forma económica política y
social para tener una respuesta conjunta
la respuesta conjunta es lo que quieren
estos dos mandatarios de cara a lo que
se vendría después de que el gobierno de
yo bailé levanten precisamente la medida
del título 42 el levantamiento de esta
medida se quedaría el 23 de mayo esto es
importante tener en cuenta el
levantamiento de esta medida porque está
medido estero versión agua habilitaba la
patrulla fronteriza en la frontera entre
méxico y eeuu a expulsar a cualquier
inmigrante que haya entrado a eeuu con
el pretexto de salud pública de cara al
hobbit 19 y con el levantamiento
entonces lo que está empezando a pasar
es que ya muchos migrantes de varios
países de centroamérica de latinoamérica
incluso ucranianos en la frontera están
empezando a llegar y a llenar la frente
entre méxico y eeuu y precisamente en
marzo fue el mes donde más migrantes se
han detenido en eeuu en las últimas dos
décadas así que hay mucha preocupación
no solamente en eeuu sino precisamente
en méxico que oficiales ya les habían
oficiales mexicanos ya habían compartido
esa preocupación de eeuu diciéndole que
si en caso de que se levantara esta
medida las olas de migrantes que
llegarán a méxico tratando de pasar a
eeuu iban a llegar a cifras récord y
terminamos en argentina los comedores
populares buscan alternativas para
continuar alimentando a millones de
ciudadanos que lo necesitan y es que la
alta inflación que presenta el país
suramericano ha provocado un alza
considerable en los precios de los
alimentos
la inflación sigue desafiando a los
argentinos el comedor beneficiario de
elena gonzález ubicado a unos 55
kilómetros de buenos aires no da abasto
para asistir a las personas que buscan
un plato de comida con tres o cuatro
gallinas y su imponente huerta el
ingenio de esta mujer hace que con una
cocina de leña para ahorrar el gas
alcance la comida desde este comedero
aseguran que cada vez es más complicado
asistir a las familias de barrios
humildes y hay una inflación muy alta
sobre los alimentos esa inconstancia
hace de que uno nunca sepa bien que va a
tener para cocinar entonces cómo
sobrevivimos como tenemos tantos
comedores y merenderos funcionando
argentina tiene uno de los mayores
índices de inflación en el mundo en
marzo registró una inflación interanual
el 55 1% la mayor de sudamérica después
de venezuela los alimentos subieron un
20% sólo en el primer trimestre de este
año se estima que en este país
suramericano donde la tasa de pobreza
cerró en el 2021 en 30 y 73 según el
gobierno llega a unos 4 millones de
personas que dependen de los subsidios
estatales para comer las organizaciones
siempre nos plantean es la necesidad de
leche no la leche es un alimento que por
lo general
no es que en para mucho todos los años
en forma constante y además tratamos a
veces de buscarle la vuelta así por ahí
no viene do nada de tratar de conseguir
comprando con dinero que nos dan los
donantes el gobierno argentino ha
intentado tomar medidas aumentando el 50
por ciento a los cupones de alimentos
que pasó de 78 dólares a 156 por mes
además intenta frenar el fenómeno
inflacionario
acordando con los supermercados
retrotraer los precios de múltiples
productos creando un fideicomiso para
estabilizar el precio del trigo y
avanzando en sus negociaciones con el
fondo monetario internacional a pesar de
los esfuerzos el banco mundial proyectó
un crecimiento del pib para argentina
del 36 % para el 2022 en un momento en
el que las consecuencias de la guerra en
ucrania han afectado la recuperación
post pandemia
hasta aquí las noticias sigan conectados
con france24
[Música]